Welcome back.
I was running out of time in
the last video and I was
afraid that I was jumbling up
the problem just to get in
under the wire.
So I just drew the triangle.
Actually, let me do it over
since I have all the time in
the world now.
Because I really want
you to get this.
So the original parallelogram
looks like this.
This is a diagonal.
And they tell us that all of
these sides are congruent, so
that means that they're
all the same length.
So this side is equal to the
side is equal to this side,
this side is equal
to this side.
So that also tells you these
are both equilateral
triangles, all the sides are
equals so all these angles,
this must be 60, this must be
60, this must be 60, this must
be 60, 60 and 60.
Now what else do we know?
They want us to figure out the
ratio of this diagonal, the
long diagonal to this shorter
diagonal right here.
We know the shorter diagonals
of length 1.
And with parallelograms, you
might already kind of know
this, and actually we could
prove this to you.
Since all of these lines
are congruent, we know
that-- we know what?
What is this angle right here?
What is half of-- this line
is going to bisect
both of these angles.
How do we know?
Well if it didn't bisect
it, all the
sides wouldn't be congruent.
So we know that this side is 30,
this side is 30, this is
30, this is 30.
And we also know that for any
parallelogram-- actually for
any rhombus-- the two soon.
diagonals are going to be
perpendicular bisectors
of each other.
It's not true for any
parallelogram, it's only true
when the sides are
all congruent.
In this situation, and we
already know this because this
is a 30 degree angle, this is
a 60 degree angle, so what
does this have to be?
This has to be a 90 degree
angle because they have
to add up to 180.
So let's just pick numbers.
Let's say that this side is 1,
this side is 1, this side is
1, this side is 1.
Then this entire diagonal here
would be 1, half of it would
be 1/2, this would be 1/2,
this would be 1/2.
If we didn't know it was 1/2, we
could just say well this is
a 30, 60, 90 triangle.
So the 30 degree side is
1/2 of the hypotenuse.
And then what else do we know
about 30, 60, 90 triangles?
The 60 degree side is squares
of 3 times the shorter side.
So this side is going to be
square root of 3 over 2.
And all we did is we realized
that this is
a 30, 60, 90 triangle.
And then we were using the
principle of 30, 60, 90
triangle to figure out that
the side opposite the 60
degree side is square
root of 3 over 2.
If that side is square root of
3 over 2, then this is also
square root of 3 over 2.
So what's this entire length?
It'd be square root of 3 over
2 plus square root of 3 over
2, which is equal to
square root of 3.
You add two halves of anything
you get the whole.
So the square roots of 3.
So the purple diagonal is square
roots of 3, and what is
this-- this was d and c.
This is ac.
So we know that ac is equal
to the square root of 3.
And we also know that d-- I'm
sorry, this is a b-- db is
equal to 1.
We just defined it as 1.
So the ratio of ac to bd or
db is going to be square
root of 3 to 1.
And that is choice B.
I hope I didn't confuse you.
Next section-- actually, we just
finished that section.
I'll see you